welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and spoilers for thor love and
thunder ahead because we're going to be
talking about the second post-credits
scene that formerly introduced valhalla
to the mcu i hope you're gone because i
just spoiled it so i hope you're gone oh
my god please leave if you haven't seen
this movie it's specifically how i
believe that one anthony edward stark is
about to meet up with the coolest
gravity scientist thor has ever
rollerbladed with within that holy
hallowed hall of heroes and let me tell
you why i've entered babies but before
we do be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to find our newest
latest obsession shirt inspired by thor
love and thunder and also miss marvel
both of those shirts are amazing and can
be bought over at new rockstarsmerch.com
so hit up rockstarsmerch.com today
alright so thor love and thunder of
course at the very end finally
introduced the realm of valhalla to the
marvel cinematic universe establishing
that in order to gain admittance into a
valhalla you must be a god who died in
battle and i believe that tony stark is
one of those gods mostly because of what
appears to be at the mcu's secret
apparent definition as to what a god is
in the mcu and it looks like to me that
what makes you a god in the mcu is
having a crazy amount of cosmic energy
flowing throughout your nervous system
that's it really for example our first
ever real look at what a god's biology
looks like sort of came in the form of
ego the living planet in guardians of
the galaxy vol 2. what are you exactly
i'm what's called a celestial sweetheart
a celestial like a god
small g son ego was literally just a
big-ass brain filled with blue cosmic
energy at the very center of his planet
and a little bit later in that movie
peter quill himself becomes a god by
connecting with and channeling the
unbelievably massive amounts of cosmic
energy that lived inside of ego's planet
and after peter made that connection to
the light within ego's planet ego
specifically tells peter that death
would be a stranger to him because he is
now a god oh peter death will remain a
stranger to both of us as long as the
light burns within the planet and we
also see this shown in chongqi and the
legend of the ten rings when the blue
dark energy of the ten rings kept wenwu
from dying for centuries and gifted him
god-like power and authority like he had
all that cosmic energy flowing in his
blood and we can see as much in that
little close-up shot with his arm before
baby groot killed eagle the living
planet like the god butcher that he is
ego was a master of massive amounts of
blue cosmic energy a cosmic godly energy
that has intrigued a lot of entities in
the mcu in the past you know people like
red skull the blue cosmic energies of
the tesseract known in the mcu as dark
energy and there is even an entire
research facility dedicated to looking
into the dark energy inside of the
tesseract you know before loki destroyed
the joint dark energy research facility
at the beginning of avengers 1 and
that's the same place that marvel did a
lot of research in while she was alive
thor odinson himself is a massive dark
energy conduit which is why he was able
to completely decimate hella's army
without the aid of mjolnir in for
ragnarok and also why his lightning is
blue in the mcu and never yellow like
electros or even gold like zeus's
lightning it's always specifically blue
and hey speaking of zeus what makes zeus
himself a god isn't just his ability to
decide who is invited to the orgy ah god
i wish it were me oh no because i
believe it's the massive amount of
golden energy that courses through his
vain violent veins which is why we see
in the movie that the blood of the gods
are gold it's because gods like zeus and
the god of gore's planet are all
conduits of golden soul singularity
energy the same type of energy that
flows in the synthetic bodies of earth's
many gods the eternals and why the
eternals wake up in front of mcu earth's
golden sun after charging their bodies
up with its energy at the very beginning
of the movie like you can even call it
soul singularity because soul means some
and this is basically why captain marvel
is stronger than thor in the mcu as we
saw play out in season one of what if
captain marvel has more cosmic energies
flowing within her body with both blue
and golden energies powering her being
like the entirety of captain marvel 1
was a movie about carol danvers
unlocking her golden energy abilities by
learning how to believe in her own self
because her golden power is the power
that everyone on mcu earth is entitled
to because it's the golden energy from
the sun which is why all the sorcerers
in commerce use golden energy for their
you know portals and stuff and she only
really used her blue dark energy powers
that she got from the tesseract for the
first two acts of the film thor himself
would not get access to this type of
golden power until he started wielding
the golden thunderbolt of zeus halfway
through thor love and thunder and when
that happened the power of thor became a
combination of blue dark energy and gold
soul singularity and that is very much
represented in his actual attire
throughout the film he wears blue and
gold and also considering that aeroshim
told us that celestials are literally
born from the aggregated golden energies
of intelligent life energy levels really
do determine your status of godhood in
the mcu which is why jane foster a
normal human woman for most of her life
was able to enter valhalla at the very
end of her life because her body was
flowing with both the blue and golden
energies that were coursing through for
odinsen's body at the end of the filming
and it's all because the very
enchantment that odin put into the
hammer it's like whosoever is worthy
gets the power of four the power of thor
odinson and at that time he was wielding
his normal blue powers alongside the
orange powers of zeus's thunderbolt so
yeah jane foster died in battle with the
status of a god and those are the
prerequisites to enter valhalla i cannot
think of a human being that has had more
cosmic energy in their body than tony
stark did during the final avengers
battle because tony stark had not won
cosmic singularity like the eternals not
two cosmic singularities like captain
marvel or even the scarlet witch who at
the time of one division multiverse of
madness was in possession of red chaos
energy and yellow mind stone energy from
vision tony stark himself had all six
core energies of the mcu coursing
throughout his soon to be fried body and
he used those energies to save the
entire universe from certain doom you
know more than the gods of the universe
were using their energies for anyway
they were just chilling like at the last
moment of his life tony stark wielded
the power of a god and became like a god
like jane foster which is why jane
foster likely had dinner with the
flirtatious tony stark in the halls of
valhalla right after she arrived but
also as a side note we cannot forget how
tony stark himself was basically a man
in god armor ever since iron man 2 when
he used howard stark's dark energy
science that howard learned from the
tesseract to make him a new arc reactor
a blue dark energy arc reactor that got
juiced up in avengers 1 after being hit
by thor's dark energy lightning it's all
gone power baby it all connects hashtag
the marvel trigger theory that's a
reference to a theory i did a couple
months ago about how all the energies of
the mcu are linked to certain aspects of
our reality it's really interesting
check it out but that is why i believe
anthony edward stark is in valhalla as
we speak what do you guys think let us
know in the comment section below but of
course thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some really weird [ __ ] and
really fun theories but most importantly
you can follow new rock stars wherever
we are on social media and when you do
on youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and of course hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to find our newest
latest obsession shirts inspired by both
ms marvel and thor love and thunder we
love you guys so much so so much please
be safe we'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
you